رغم ان قريه السوق الغرب المسيحيه تقع بين
قريتين شيعيتين الا ان حزب الله اختارها
احد الشوارعها لبناء فرع جديد للقرض الحسن
هذا اول مبنى يشيده حزب الله خارج حدود
بيئته رغم ارتفاع الاصوات المناهضه للدور
المصري في الذي يلعبه
رئيس بلديه سوق الغرب التابع للتيار
الوطني الحر اعطى الاذن لتشييد البناء رغم
معرضه النسبه الاكبر من اعضاء البلديه اذا
معه ضد افتتاح القرض الحسن هون
ضد اما السكان فقللون منهم وافقوا على
التعليق امام الكاميرا خاصه وانهم على
مرمى حجر من كره تناصر حزب الله 11 بلديه
رفضوا راس البلديه يحطوا البنك
المفروض يحطوا بمطيه بكيف
الجمعيه التي اسست على فرضيه العمل الخيري
قبل اربعين عاما تمددت وتمادت مستفيده من
انهيار القطاع المصرفي وفيما توقفت
المصارف عن تقديم القرود رفعت الجمعيه عدد
افرعها الى 31 فرعا وقدمت قرودا بدون
فوائد عبر رهن ذهاب وممتلكات ونشرت
ماكينات الصراف الالي ضاربه بقانون النقد
والتسليف عرض الحائط يجب ان يحضع التسليف
لاحكام القانون هذا الشيء ما عمله ولكن
نمط حزب الله ان يحل دائما محل مؤسسات
الحكوميه وان يعطل المؤسسات الدستوريه هيك
عمل باليمن هيك عمل بالعراق هيك عامل
بسوريا هيك عامل بلبنان واليوم بالسودان
ينطلق اذا بدك من جهاز
خليني اقول مصري في معين يلي هو بلش فيه
من جمعيه خيريه خلينا نقول تتوصل مرحله
تصير هي بتقود اغلبيه الحركه الاقتصاديه
عند حزب الله يعني في شيء بدعي للتساؤل
فانا برايي لازم بمعزل عن المسيحيين حتى
عند الشيعه حتى عند السنه حتى عند
المسيحيين قال براي هذا اختراق
للدوله اللبنانيه لازم الدوله اللبنانيه
هي تاخد هالشي مع الاعتبار لانه بنهايه
المطاف عم بيكون في نظام مصرفي رديف
للمصرف لنظام مصرفي لبناني
ومثل كل مؤسسه حزب الله لبنان المهدد بخفض
تصنيفه الى الرمادي او الاسود يقف عجزا
امام نظام مصرفي غير مشروع سيزيد من سوء
سمعته الماليه استفاد حزب الله من انهيار
القطاع المصرفي فبنى مؤسساته على انقاذ
الدوله بعد ان وصف لاعوام بدوله داخل دوله
غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت